pourquoi on pense comme ça j'ai pas la
réponse n'est pas la vérité révélée mais
à mon avis c'est parce que les seuls
scientifiques qui sont médiatisés sont
des prix nobel lina miolane n'a pas
encore de prix nobel n'a pas les cheveux
blancs et ne semble pas enfermer dans un
monde parallèle
et pourtant la jeune chercheuse est déjà
reconnue pour son travail
à 26 ans une thèse sur la médecine
numérique en poche elle parcourt les
établissements scolaires yvelinois pour
tenter de contrer les idées reçues qui
entoure son travail on imagine tout de
suite un homme blanc en blouse bleue
avec des cheveux en pétard etc dans tous
les cas pas une femme
il a beaucoup de personnes qui sont
convaincus que c'est pas fait pour les
filles et aussi que les filles sont
naturellement moins bonnes comme si à
notre cerveau n'était pas disposé à
faire des sciences en france moins de
30% des chercheurs en sciences sont des
femmes pire encore les prix nobel les
home trust 97% des récompenses nina
miolane à travers son parcours parfois
compliqué souhaite ainsi donner l'envié
aux plus jeunes de faire des études
scientifiques
moi je pensais que par exemple pour être
scientifique et en fait non lt pas du
tout habillé comme ça même s'il a pas
encore beaucoup de femmes dans le
domaine scientifique je pense qu'il ya
plus de différence et yappa ya plus
vraiment les stores et type de l'ancien
temps je pense que ça a changé
d'ici quelques jours la jeune chercheuse
yvelinois s'envolera aux états unis pour
la suite de sa carrière professionnelle
elle espère pouvoir y continuer ses
interventions pour les femmes et la
science